this is june and what is june people it
is l g b t
q
i plus l m n o p month okay
and that means you have to put up a flag
it once was the rainbow flag people
enjoyed the rainbow you see a rainbow oh
what's on the other side of the rainbow
what's at the end of the rainbow it's a
pot of gold a little leprechaun very
nice now it's complete insanity okay now
it's lesbians with penises it's uh what
else do they got they got they got the
whole thing out there
anyway it is lgbt pride month and what
does disney plus have for us well
they've got a new drag queen show for
kids
[Music]
hello
and welcome to the disney plus this is
me pride celebration spectacular i'm
nina west and i'm here to guide you
through a magical musical and
meaningful celebration of the lgbtq plus
community glsen's mission is to create
safe and inclusive schools for lgbtq
plus students in grades k-12 and disney
plus is so proud to support this
wonderful organization for more
information visit www.glsen.org
[Music]
forward slash pride phoenix i want to
thank you for having the barf bag next
to me while we were playing that clip i
i've just had it with these people like
what does that have to do with children
it has nothing to do with children if
you wish to dress up
as an adult as any gender wear a
ridiculous wig put on a lot of lipstick
blah blah blah do whatever the hell you
want but this should have nothing to do
with children and also this has nothing
to do with gay people or lesbians this
trans thing the lg and even the bee
the confused bees they have nothing to
do with the tea thing and the fact that
disney plus this giant corporate
conglomerate is pushing this stuff on
children i cancel disney plus i
recommend you cancel
disney plus and if you're showing that
to your kids do you think that those
people those drag queens there that
those are happy highly functioning
people who are going to do really well
in society and build lasting families
and be productive members of the
community like it is possible i suppose
at some level right so i don't mean it
about those two
characters whatever they are
specifically but generally speaking is
this what you want to push on children
this is what you want to push on six
seven-year-olds
what do you think what do you think